had another dream last night was it a
good one or was it about me it was about
a poor wise man who changes the city I
saw his face man am I glad you guys
showed up Debbie I got a sales call 6:30
I got to drop off contracts north of
town no you don't any infectious
diseases flow around this place I should
know about
Martin told me about your friend if you
don't tell Debbie I will we've been
married 19 years we don't share the same
life we don't share anything you can
leave you choose
we have to talk to him as a man from
that dream what's your name you don't
need to know my name
well I'd like to know your name telling
a woman's too bothering me you'd be
doing me a big favor just be nicer you
want to be my for you huh
but I'm gonna have to think about we're
from after bonnet ah the man put me up
in a little shack he didn't tell me how
I could earn some money maybe even some
respect
y'all defending some homeless you lost
your mind they're looking for handouts
that he using their hands for work in
fear I won't even know me done some bad
things you're not a bad man
friends very sexy what you did the day I
got out with a homeless guy how was it
actually it was kind of amazing some
things you need to know about miss
Debbie she's the only person to call you
enough not to give up I love you Ronnie
ray
stubborn
whether Wiis rich or poor weasel
homeless just working our way back on
Denver changed everything lives together
would never be
I along with most of the other members
of a problem with you bringing your
friend around you can tell them that
yourself is standing right there